[Musique]
quand mon père manus corneau est décédé
c'est pour moi c'est la fin du monde
quoi
floriane berne oda avait 28 ans lors de
la tuerie du bataclan et lee a perdu son
amoureux son confident de toujours avec
qui elle devait se marier
nous les connu quand j'avais 16 ans et
construit ensemble
[Musique]
donc donc d'un seul coup faut apprendre
à vivre tout seul c'est ça qui est
difficile
ce soir là elle est restée cachée dans
le plafond d'une loge d'artiste pendant
de longues heures en se demandant si les
terroristes allaient la trouver je suis
resté sur la dalle à cet endroit jusqu'à
1h30 du matin
en attendant ce qui se passait et or
vous demanda si vous allez vous en
sortir
ouais ouais tout à fait au cours des
mois suivants et la éviter les foules
les transports en commun et elle a suivi
des séances de thérapie et l'a repris le
travail
changer d'emploi elle a déménagé et
commencé à fréquenter d'autres victimes
j'avais peur en fait c'était la peur et
des angoisses importante puis avaient
toutes les phases du deuil en fait que
j'avais besoin aussi d'accompagner
quelque part aussi pour les serono
partir définitivement
ans
et puis un jour elle a rencontré joannes
via les associations de victimes
présentes sur les réseaux sociaux
le besoin de combler un vide une absence
insupportable avec quelqu'un qui peut le
comprendre
[Musique]
on avait la confiance totale qu on se
comprenait c'est une sentiment où on ne
se sent plus connectés - deux jugements
récents que l'autre comprend bien ce
qu'on scande vie lyonnaise boss assisté
au même concert au bataclan le soir de
l'attaqué terroriste il a vécu lui aussi
un double traumatisme
il s'est caché derrière le bar a pensé
mourir a perdu le contact avec sa
conjointe mode et découvert le lendemain
qu'elle avait été tué
notre vie comme on la connaissait un
autre monde comme on l'a qui ne
connaissait était complètement
bouleversé même éradiquer même
et lentement leur relation a évolué moi
je dirais qu'on peut pas l'expliquer
c'est quelque chose qui arrive au
dernier pas et moi je dirais ça faisait
partie aussi de vivre ils se sont mariés
en octobre 2017 et très vite la petite
bérénice est arrivé dans leur vie c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que bérénice appel
bérénice cela veut dire qu'il porte la
victoire c'est une victoire sur la vie
c'est une victoire sur sur ce qu'on a
vécu aussi d'être toujours là et de
pouvoir continuer à se focaliser sur
l'avenir c'est un peu ce qu'on n'avait
pas réalisé finalement ou en partie avec
moderno c'était aussi une façon de
de continuer de vivre pour eux seul
ombre à ce tableau idyllique
floriane et johannes n'ont toujours pas
eu accès aux compensations financières
prévues par l'état français pour les
victimes d'actes terroristes
moi je suis pas celle expertise j'étais
enceinte de bérénice et c'est vrai que
ça a été notifiée dans le rapport qui a
été fait par la suite comme si parce
qu'aujourd'hui je me reconstruise s
était s'était finalement amoindrir le
drame que j'avais vécu on ne voit plus
basiquement de ne pas vraiment être
victime n'est pas tant victimes en juge
notre degré de des victimes de
victimisation notre droit d'être
indemnisée ou pas floriane et johannes
portent en eux la mémoire de leur
conjoint disparu
ils rêvent qu'à eux parlent d'eux c'est
ce qui leur permet de continuer à
avancer sereinement avec une petite
bérénice la vie on est fragile
chaque étape nous rend un peu plus
résignons un peu plus fort quand même
mon enfance elle s'est arrêtée
le sort du bataclan alors c'est une
enfance qui était longue ce que j'avais
28 ans mais
mais voilà j'ai aujourd'hui je me
confronte un peu plus à la réalité ou à
la dureté de la vie
je me sens plus adultes aussi plus
responsable et plus plus près thouet
plus déterminés aussi vrai
[Musique]